Okay,
that's Martin,
so the story of Martin,
I'll just give it to you very briefly.
Timeout and aps who are locked in,
embrace it at the beginning of time.
God is of salt water,
garden,
fresh water together,
chaos in order,
right?
They give rise,
masculine,
feminine.
They give rise to the world of the elder
gods and those are to me,
they're primordial motivational forces
or something like that and their rage
and their lost and their love and all
these things that possess us that are
there forever and they're out in the
world acting and they carelessly slay
appsu their father and their making a
rocket and then they collapsed and then
tie them out,
gets wind of that and that's time out
right there.
By the way,
she's kind of a rough looking creature
and she's the mother of all things and
so she's not very happy about this.
These are her children have destroyed
structure itself,
plus they're noisy and careless and so
she thinks all right,
just like,
no.
I'm just like the God that brings the
flood to know what exactly the same idea
time matt comes back and says,
yeah,
okay,
enough is enough.
I'm going to take you out,
and she makes this battalion of monsters
and puts the worst monster there is that
the head of the battalion,
his name is king who he's like a
precursor to the idea of Satan and she
lets the gods know,
hey,
I'm coming for you,
and so they're not very happy about this
because their gods.
But like,
yeah,
she's chaos itself,
right?
She gave birth to everything.
This is no joke,
and so they send one got out after
another to confront her and they all
come back with their tails between their
legs.
There is no hope and then one day
there's a new guard that emerges and
that's.
And the guards know.
As soon as he pops up,
they know he's something new.
Remember,
this is happening while the
Mesopotamians are assembling themselves
into one of the world's first great
civilizations.
So all the gods of all those tribes are
coming together to organize themselves
into a hierarchy to figure out what
proposition rules everything.
And so Marta is elected by all the gods
and he says,
look,
I'll go out there and I'll take on time
map,
but here's the rule from on,
you follow me.
I determine destiny.
I'm the top God.
I'm the thing at the top of the
hierarchy.
And all the other gods say,
hey look,
no problem.
You get rid of chaos.
We do exactly what you say.
Now Marta,
his eyes all the way around his head and
he speaks magic words.
Those are his primary attributes.
And so he takes a net and he goes out to
confront timeout.
And,
and he,
he,
he encloses her in the net,
which I think is so cool because it's an
encapsulation,
right?
It's a conceptual encapsulation.
He encloses chaos itself in a conceptual
structure.
He puts it in the net and then he cuts
her into pieces and he makes the world.
And then that he creates human beings to
inhabit that world and to serve the
gods.
And he creates human beings out of the
blood of King of the worst,
the demons.
And that took me to call Andy Young,
who was a student of mine,
helped me figure that out.
I thought that's pretty damn
pessimistic.
It's like,
you know what exactly?
It sounds like a full metaphor.
It's like the idea of original sin,
but,
but our joint conclusion
with regards to that was that human
beings are the only creatures in
creation that can truly deceive,
right?
We have the capacity for evil,
just like it says in the Adam and Eve
story.
We can actually do that.
And that's why we're made out of the
blood of King,
knew the king of the demons.
The we are the thing that can deceive,
that can twist the structure of reality.
Well.
So Marduk now the,
the team has had an emperor and the
emperor was the
Avatar of Marta.
That's what made them emperor.
He was only at Emperor.
If he was going to be Murdoch,
he had to be a good Marduk.
Which man he,
I do confront time,
chaos and cut her up and make order out
of her pieces.
And what the Mesopotamians used to do
after New Year's celebration,
they'd go outside their walled city and
that's explored territory versus
unexplored territory.
They go outside their world's city into
chaos,
and they bring all the statutes that
represented the gods and they'd act this
out because they were trying to figure
something out,
right?
You're trying to figure out what this
means.
They're acting it out,
and then they'd take their emperor and
the priest would make them kneel and
they take all his king.
He is king.
Uniform off is emperor uniform off and
make them Neil and humiliate them and
nail them with a glove and say,
okay,
how were you not a good Martech this
year?
Right?
And then he'd recount all the ways that
he was inadequate in confronting chaos.
And then they'd do the celebration and
Martech would win and the king would go
sleep with a royal prostitute.
And the reason for that was it's the
same idea as St George pulling the
Virgin from the Dragon.
It's exactly the same idea that if you
call,
if you encounter the reptilian chaos,
you can extract something out of it with
which if you unite,
you produce creative order.
That's what they were acting out and
that was the basis for the Mesopotamian
idea of sovereignty.
It's so smart.
It's so unbelievably smart and know the
Mesopotamians had a massive influence on
the civilizations that then had a
massive influence on us.
It's one of the stories of how the
notion of sovereignty itself came to be.
It's the evolution of the idea of God.
That's one way of thinking about it,
but even more importantly,
it's the evolution of the idea of the
redemptive human being.
Right,
and that's taken to.
It's one of its conclusions while in the
story of Buddha,
but also in the story of Christ,
the idea of the perfect individual and
the notion is,
well,
that's the word that speaks truth into
chaos at the beginning of time to
generate habitable order.
That is good.
That's the story,
and so with that,
let's see.
Oh sure.
I'll just show you these pictures
because they're so interesting once you
know what they mean.
They're so cool.
That's a symbol of infinity.
That's Hercules and the hydro.
Well,
what slice?
Like cut off one head.
What happens?
Seven more.
Grow,
right?
Well,
what do you do?
Run home.
Well,
no,
that's not what you do it.
This is what you do.
You fight it.